le convoi de la liberté les participants
ont réussi à entrer dans paris a
pourtant ce matin la police déployée en
nombre verbaliser les automobilistes sur
le périphérique les empêchant de
pénétrer dans la capitale notre reporter
david khalifa et avenue des champs
elysées en europe
david arbon alors quelle est la
situation actuellement
[Musique]
la situation est extrêmement tendue
amira sur les champs elysées depuis
l'arrivée du convoi de la liberté sur
l'avenue des champs-elysées et bien là
plusieurs affrontements ont eu lieu
entre forces de l'ordre et manifestants
à les forces de l'ordre qui ont tiré à
coups de gaz lacrymogènes à plusieurs
reprises sur les manifestants venus en
nombre sur cette avenue des champs
elysées c'était est un objectif de
longue date pour eux après plusieurs
jours de route après plusieurs jours
d'organisation ils ont réussi leur
objectif c'est-à-dire atteindre est les
champs elysées à ce convoi de la liberté
bloque totalement l'avenir depuis
plusieurs depuis maintenant un peu plus
d'une heure les forces de l'ordre
interviennent à plusieurs reprises ans
pour pouvoir a dispersé les manifestants
les certains à deux des touristes ont
été gazés un para para les tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes tirés par les forces de
l'ordre en direction des manifestants
un des touristes assez choqué il faut le
dire un parent par ce dispositif de
sécurité assez conséquents qui était
mise en place pour encadrer ce convoi de
la liberté je rappelle que sept mille
deux cents gendarmes et policiers ont
été déployés par le préfet 10 et
l'allemand qui a mis tous les moyens
humains et matériels afin d'éviter le
blocage de la capitale pour c'est un
convoi de la liberté arrivés en masse au
sein aux portes de paris depuis ce matin
on dénombre plus de 350 verbalisation
opéré à par la police depuis ce matin et
puis la situation je vous le disais à
plusieurs reprises soudainement ça ça
peut arriver à un trader de manière très
soudaine regardez ces images de
sébastien dufour où les forces de
l'ordre interviennent là vous voyez la
brave 1 qui intervient actuellement à
pour tenter de disperser la c1
manifestants acquis un bloc pour le
moment la circulation sur les champs
elysées sur plusieurs un moment précis
et c'est vrai qu'à plusieurs reprises
nous avons dû subir à ces tirs de gaz
lacrymogène en grande quantité un pour
les manifestants mais aussi pour la
passer et aussi pour les touristes je
vous le disais qu'ils étaient assez
choqué en tout cas l'objectif il est
bien là un dénoncé évidemment les
mesures liberticides prises par le
gouvernement depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire des knicks est aussi un
gouvernement totalement déconnectés de
la réalité
malgré à tous ces dispositifs de
sécurité assez conséquent et tous ces
dispositions a mis en place par le
préfet l'allemand comme regarder un ces
images de sébastien dufour et bien les
manifestants sont plus déterminés que
jamais à se faire entendre aujourd'hui
c'était un soulagement pour eux c'était
une joie immense de pouvoir
pouvoir fouler à cette avenue des champs
elysées un objectif de longue date voilà
encore une fois sur ces images regarder
à sébastien duffo ça vient de tirer des
gaz lacrymogènes là devant la devant une
grande enseigne de marque ce qui
évidemment nous rappelle un 2-2 sombre
image de fin 2018 et des et des
manifestations dédiées gilet jaune on se
souvient que les champs elysées était
souvent pris d'assaut est en tout cas ce
qu'on veut la liberté atteint son
objectif et ne compte pas baisser les
bras compte se faire entendre jusqu'au
bout de sept journées voilà vous voyez
juste en direct sur ces images encore
une fois des tirs de gaz lacrymogènes
tirés en direction des manifestants qui
sont dispersés où il allait très
compliqué du coup de deux pouvoirs de
pouvoir s'y retrouver c'est vrai que à
plusieurs reprises avec mon caméraman
nous avons été séparés plus que les
charges ont été multiples sur cette
avenue des champs elysées je vous
propose d'écouter quelques-uns des des
manifestants justement que nous avons pu
interroger à ce matin et l'or leur but
imprécis écoutez
dans deux jours il va y avoir 5 millions
de personnes qui vont perdre leur pass
sanitaires à cause du fait qu'ils
n'aient pas fait leur troisième dose et
viennent d'annoncer avant-hier dès que
le deck le convoi a démarré que le pass
annie terre va s'arrêter de famars donc
il va durer six mois six semaines encore
se passe sanitaire et ils continuent à
obliger les gens à aller se faire
vacciner ce qui est complètement stupide
alors je suis venu parce que pour nos
libertés pour respecter nos droits
fondamentaux et j'ai beaucoup aimé les
différentes phases du voyage parce que
hier par exemple à 3 c'était mémorable
et je suis surprise de voir qu'à paris
tout est beaucoup plus compliquées alors
que le pacifisme et est de rigueur j'ai
l'impression qu'il ait pas eu de mot il
ya pas eu de débordement et pourtant
tout de suite on a vu les forces de
l'ordre arrivées débarqué je crois qu'on
arrive à une saturation on arrive ainsi
un arrogant c'est une provocation qui
devient jeu devient insupportable
surtout entre les changements permanents
de situations et de mesure et derrière
se passe
vaccinale maintenant moi je dirais qu'on
est content copains qui passent
sanitaire au pass vaccinale mais que la
plupart des gens ne sont pas dupes on
tend vers un citoyen c'est-à-dire vie
d'un bon contrôle de plus en plus les
gens c'est une réalité c'est pas du tout
du complotisme c'est ce sont des faits
c'est factuel cette grande mobilisation
des forces de l'ordre les manifestants
continuent de se positionner entre cette
avenue des champs elysées afin
d'exprimer leur colère en vous l'aurez
compris à l'objectif principal c'est le
retrait de ce pass vaccinale et la
mobilisation va se poursuivre tout au
long de l'après midi ici même sur cette
avenue des champs-elysées